good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson said imagine you're Joe Biden
and you're required to give a State of
the Union Address because it's in the
Constitution
so if you're buying it would take a lot
of brass to stand up on live television
and claim the U.S is better off than it
was when you took over
could you do that well in a little more
than an hour Joe Biden will do that if
only it were true it's not true this
country is more divided less
self-confident more confused and sadder
than it's been in living memory for the
first time in Generations we Face the
actual risk of a World War
our problems are fixable but they are
profound and they require the full
attention of wise and serious leaders
who love the country and who are willing
to think beyond the next election
instead unfortunately we've got Joe
Biden and Kamal Harris in the cast of
mediocrities who stand behind them
making the actual decisions
so if we had to guess we would guess
that Biden is going to use his speech
tonight is he had another opportunity to
brag about his victories and blame his
failures on others January 6 Vladimir
Putin we don't expect a single honest
word we hope we're surprised but we
don't expect to be in the meantime
here's as close to we can get as a
statistical analysis of the actual State
of the Union under Joe Biden
since his predecessor Donald Trump gave
his final address to the Joint session
of the Congress the cost of food Staples
in the United States a pretty good
measure has risen by more than 20
percent the price of gasoline has gone
up by more than 40 and Diesel even
higher consumer confidence meanwhile is
the mirror image it's dropped by 40
percent
what's risen is credit card debt that's
now at an all-time high over a trillion
dollars cumulatively it is estimated and
homelessness as well there are now tens
of thousands more Americans living on
the streets than there were when Joe
Biden became president
he'll ignore that fact tonight
guaranteed what could he say about it on
the other hand how could he ignore it
but again he will
interest rates meanwhile have
skyrocketed the number of new home
buyers is lower than it's been at any
point in modern history the number of
working age American men who are
actually working is now under 68 percent
take a look at the graph on your screen
if anything is an emergency that's an
emergency
but it's being ignored we'll just import
new workers and that's why the southern
border of the United States is open
tonight as it has been for two years and
because it's opened millions and
millions and millions millions of
foreign Nationals have streamed across
into our country illegally
in many cases we know nothing about them
at all we can't even imagine how their
presence long term will affect our
economy or already strained Social
Services the ones you paid for your
entire life
you think Health Care is in shambles now
go ahead and visit an emergency room in
five years good luck getting treatment
but the real cost to the country is in
Social cohesion this is just too many
new people doesn't matter whether
they're good people or bad people
they're strangers
and there are too many of them there's
no chance we could assimilate all of
them
and at this point we have enough
problems with our social fabric all on
our own
here's one measure in March of 2020 31
of Americans told Gallup that they quote
worried a great deal about race
when Joe Biden took office that number
went up to nearly 50 percent and of
course it's all the administration talks
about race
is not a solvable condition it's genetic
it never changes so if you focus on It
ultimately you'll make people hate each
other
and that's what's happening
that might make you anxious about the
future but of course our future is
education all of us have heard that
since birth in this country so how are
our schools doing under Joe Biden well
here's one measure the national average
ACT score in 2022 hit its lowest level
in more than three decades SAT scores
have gone down too now just over 40
percent of all test takers 40 percent
meet or exceed standards in Reading
Writing and math
test results in certain cities are even
worse in Baltimore for example at least
23 schools have not a single student not
one student in the whole school
proficient in math
so how is the Biden Administration
responding to this are there alarms
going off in the education department no
schools are just
failing to measure the failure they're
getting rid of standardized tests up and
down the chain including Harvard which
just made them optional the American Bar
Association says law students don't even
need to take the LSAT anymore because
tests are racist
so there's a lot of concern Express
concern about racial Justice and Equity
has that helped people well it's made a
few people very rich the ladies who are
in Black lives matter have a lot of
houses
but how are ordinary people doing are
they better off for all of it no
life expectancy the United States has
continued to decline
for all races black and white Americans
it's now at its lowest level life
expectancy in over 25 years
now that's not just due to covid those
numbers have been declining every year
for the past four years suicides up
roughly five percent that we know of
Overdose deaths up more than 50 percent
since before the pandemic alcohol deaths
of more than 30 percent
now these aren't so much medical
problems as they are famously deaths of
despair
and what's jarring is that there doesn't
seem to be an option for many Americans
a lot of people in this country don't
think they can be saved church
membership has just dropped below 50 for
the first time ever in the history of
this country
so it's a sad secular country with
decreasing reservoirs of Hope and
Military enlistment is a pretty good
measure of how people feel about that
the Pentagon has fallen short short of
its enlistment targets by 25 percent
that's more than 15
000 recruits
so what's growing and thriving in this
country under Joe Biden what weed
dispensaries are they're popping up
everywhere and the bite Administration
is encouraging this that's the Biden
economy weed dispensaries backed by
private equity
cannabis sales have exploded in this
country gone from 12 billion dollars
to more than 30 billion dollars a year
so we're building back better we're
building a lot of weed dispensaries it's
not exactly what we were promised we'll
stop the analysis there but you get the
point the question is what will Biden
say about all of this now an honest man
who cared about the country would
identify the problems honestly so we
could solve them take responsibility for
some shift the blame on others that's
okay but tell us the truth if people are
dying younger killing themselves living
on the street if credit card debt is at
an all-time high you can't tell us the
state of the union is strong
and if you can't tell us that
we can't fix it hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else